réponse avec toi tu dire une photo
finish à l'origine aux routes elles ont
à nouveau dit nobody est au point mort
ok équipe
oui adorons de football jeudi de fred je
vends de 6-2 après celle gagnée
please respecte de route soit 0,5
realization with me aïe kentelioù hockey
sont écrits boni respecte trop les i
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et en arrivant à sainte anne qui est un
domaine français et l'injure qui était
assez classique il ya eu un moment de
d'énervement entre des équipes de
sécurité
il me revenait d'y mettre bon ordre
aurait expliquant quelles sont les
règles
depuis que la france ainsi quelques
domaines et c'est vrai pour sainte-anne
la sécurité israélienne qui a fait un
travail formidable
les côtés dans les rues tout a été très
calme elle s'arrête aux portes de sainte
anne c'est la sécurité française qui
prend le relais
[Musique]
comme premier volet médico légaux ou non
vers ce nouvel incident devant l'église
sainte anne de mey national français
bras des soldats israéliens ont pris
place à l'intérieur
jacques chirac refuse d'entrer
cette génération en existe alors quitté
les lieux
le président peut alors rencontré le
patriarche monseigneur ce là bas
je rentrais
[Musique]
à midi à l'hôtel king davies benjamin
netanyahu présente ses excuses et mais
ces incidents sur le compte du
perfectionnisme des services de sécurité
depuis l'assassinât d'itzhak rabin il y
a un an si l'on pense à la recherche non
pas du tout parce que je pensais que ça
se passerait bien parfois il ya des
moments où ils cherchent la bonne limite
si beaucoup de choses sont des histoires
de frontières vous savez parfois de
limiter donc il faut jamais fait limite
ne soient franchies et on peut se le
dire même quand il ya des tons qui monte
avec beaucoup d'amitié
[Musique]